willst du hast quasi jetzt irgendwie so
ein trick wie man trotzdem auf dem pc
nutzen kann
ja krass hat über alte idol über die
qualität würde mütze auf hallo ich meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde minecraft happy bird in
minecraft also minecraft larry bird ist
das in minecraft ist sagt der name
selbst zusammen mit max hey was zu hören
wir sehen das explodiert gerade mal
vielleicht ein bisschen lauter machen
ganze scheiße wir spielen gerade was
spielen wir dann gerade max wird es
absolut willig ja bei mir ist es egal ob
der kaiser sein dass man die warsteiner
eingehen den spielen der sechs
vielleicht schaffen wir spielen heute
flecki bird bzw fleckenteppich schicken
in minecraft wie heißt die adresse max
merken drei sekunden erst alle aufgaben
etwa im vol.at hsv.de smv botnet ist das
richtig max
das ist können die leute hier spielen
viele typen fleißig das ist eine fläche
für ein spiel funktioniert das ist das
ein tolles spiel also ihr seht
vielleicht schon beim werten herrn kraft
dass er gerade ein süßes hühnchen hier
durch die gegend steuert und ja er macht
das halt auf die 6 uhr des batman im
hintergrund des sowie fläche bird
einfach nur in minecraft und man wird
automatisch mit gruft sozusagen und muss
probieren das unity nähe zwischen diesen
stäbchen hindurch zu kriegen wickelt ist
tui sie mal high scores 3 es ist viel
schwieriger als es normalerweise weiß
ich was dafür nie gespielt oder doch ich
hab fläche wird der preiskampf 133 ja
ach ja dass sie gespielt welche spieler
hast du dann noch nie gespielt
denn hier runtergeladen irgendwas war
das habe ich nicht mehr habe ich nie
gesagt nichts mehr das vielleicht ein
flirt habe ich aber jetzt mal hand der
ganzen zeit muss man die unterlagen
konnte nicht gehabt ich war erst gibt's
da und hast du heute laden mit jailbreak
als es nicht mehr im server
ich bin der
wo guckt immer die tore durch durch muss
und befolgt das extreme wenn die rede
ist dann auch schaffen würde ich wenn
ich es schaffe damit ich kenne ja du
hast ja auch deine ich hab drei wert bei
xwb es wird eine zuschauers gefragt dass
wir die ein süßes mädchen auf twitter
schreiben an twitter könnt ihr folgen
mir hashtag also das hashtag ändert
immer das ist jetzt gerade kranken oder
kontra nkran kommt ja da wurden einige
fragen schon gestellt
hier ist eine ganz lustige wieso ist die
big room meldete wächst oder ist das so
ich weiß es gar nicht wird man ja das
stimmt weiß ich gar nichts welche kräfte
hättest du gern also ich will richtig
geld
da ich mit gomez schon mal drüber
geredet und zweite ich richtig gern die
kraft die zeit zurückzudrehen
ok in manchen situationen als wendige
zum beispiel hat ein unfall muss oder
wenn er etwa einer über die schuhe
irgendwie sagt kommst du direkt drauf
oder wenn du einfach geraten streit
hatte sind das einfach etwas falsches
gesagt was ich sagen wollte nach links
auf die zeit zum ziehen sie konstrukts
drehen
aber da muss halt die komplette welt
zurück trainer verändert sich halt alles
nach
das ist dann immer so ein bisschen
komisch iris kraft es gibt auch ein ganz
cool film darüber oder so von hollywood
hollywood mäßig was den ganzen tag ist
er halt in time glaube ich ja genau der
so richtig geil den lege ich euch nur
ins herzen und ans herz weil da geht es
darum dass man das nicht geld die
währung ist an zeit oder wie war das
denn sieben vielleicht bei einem anderen
film auf jeden fall mit dem samuel
jackson der king of the dogs und jungen
jetzt gehst du arbeiter jungen g
abkommen schonkost yahoo
17 tagen nichts weiter erzählt ich habe
nicht gesehen dass du abgegangen
bisschen wird die auch mit gut 80 ist in
frage von nächste frage von luisa wunsch
ihr könnt einen tag lang die zeit
anhalten niemand kann sich bewegen was
würdet ihr machen wo passt jetzt richtig
geile frage ist wirklich sehr cool
fragen auf jeden fall dass folge deinen
zeiten ändern dich dann halt die zeit
mit drin und bushido weil er zurzeit den
medien steht etwas was 17 oder das sind
ich habe den puck aber in den
kommentaren euren highscore ich will
jetzt wieder die bahn sieht
unterschreiben kann die auch videos
schicken aber ich kann nicht auf etwas
wenn ich jetzt hier hintergründe ob
jemand ein highscore schlage ich zu den
palast ein alter bei achter nicht
abgesagt
eine hundertschaft und wenn wir 100
schafft da komme ich zu dir bloß maximal
90 90 lass mich dann abstürzte
ja ich will nicht dass sechser hinfahren
muss die kostet ja auch hoch schutz wie
windows so da fragt jetzt angelina was
denkt ihr über fernbeziehung hattet ihr
schon mal eine oder 797 war dass sie mal
schon
ersetzen von werbung erzählt ist die
kacke eigentlich also natürlich wenn
meine person liebt die 90 personen liebt
die wie ein diamant fläche chicken nur 0
schafft ja ja genau wenn man einfach
eine null ist im leben so wie max
einfach fast nie flabbee wird gespielt
hat oder nicht verkennen die kraft
besitzt ich habe natürlich in vollkommen
fernbeziehungen vollkommen legitim auch
mal sagen jeder seine eigene meinung
dies ist meine meinung wenn man jetzt
eine person quasi im urlaub kennenlernen
bei uns war es ja so als wir zusammen
urlaub war gab es ein paar beziehungen
und die haben alle die standgehalten
obwohl's fernbeziehungen wurden mehr
oder weniger verstanden ja mal in stand
gehalten weil es halt ich bei
fernbeziehungen immer so ist das bei
fernbeziehungen du kannst halt du hast
ja wie ich noch keinen kontakt kannst
was kalt muss was alles das ist
natürlich wenn du einer normalen
beziehung ist was heißt normal also
normal beziehung ganze skype mir im
urlaub ist dann alles möglich das
natürlich klar wenn du zwei wochen weg
bist aber wenn du jetzt komplett dicht
du weißt du siehst dich erst irgendwie
weiß ich nicht du siehst dich wirklich
nur alle zwei wochen und bis nicht nur
einfach mal alle zwei wochen eine zwei
wochen weg und sie ist die danach wieder
für ein paar monate dann sondern du
siehst wirklich nur alle zwei wochen
fällig das blöd eigentlich mag
fernbeziehung nicht so und ich finde es
gibt quasi 40 als mega scheiße ich sag
es auch nicht bevor man so was ein geht
es gibt genug mädchen oder frauen oder
wenn ihr eine freude die jungen genug
jungs auf dieser welt die bei euch in
der nähe kumpel von mir ich wohne ja bei
bielefeld und da ist es ein kumpel von
mir und ihr halt auch der heißt simon
und er hat eine freundin in dortmund und
das ist eingespielt anderer er sieht
normaler haushalt sich noch also normal
aus als team gespielt nicht so mit
dreadlocks und eine freundin in dortmund
in der fährt wirklich jedes wochenende
hin
also er geht einfach nicht wir kommen
unseren
liegt er richtig durch die ganze sache
der aufnahme wählen
wichtig ist crazy alter mann kann sich
auch noch andere tiere bei mir wärst du
einfach genauso oft die waren ja junge
richtig scheiße gerade ich glaub ich
muss ausgerechnet starten
das reagiert richtig spielt reagiert
richtig schlafen lassen die wand in die
wand ja eltern reagiert richtig spielt
liga reagiert richtig spielt es
geschafft ja ich bin erst kratzer
bisschen umdenken als wäre ich so zu
spät weißt du all dieser stelle
berichtet wird ihr gern die nachricht
von iz 4609 besser was sachs erste and
elephant dollar dollar an alle fans
stellt spiel du mal als pact hätte ich
nicht mal mache ich das jetzt statt game
also was ich bin auch im leben drin und
zu vermischen
was weiß ich erst mal drücken schläppi
spectator krankhaft also ich persönlich
halte von fernbeziehungen auch nicht
sehr viel selbst du schon dabei ok ich
halte davon 14 dions super spiel weil es
ist halt scheiße will irgendwie geht es
bei beziehungen ja auch stark
jetzt hat dann fliegt dass das bald auf
mich zu und sagt jutta geschubst ich
liebe schlechtreden nicht durch kann ich
doch nicht kaputtmachen schade für ihn
sind die richtig viele sind ja bei mir
läuft am 18
game over
ich will meine decke geflogen ich
nachher fotos gemacht so wie du
können wir nicht hier so springe ich
halte ich halte von fernbeziehungen
modelle audi collies richtig scheiße
hatte ich ruf dich mal ganz kurz neuen
skype an so die maxime total scheiße
aber das heißt ja als vier bands sagen
was ich weiß nein nix also ja der
beziehung weiß nicht mehr haben wir noch
mal war ich gucke jetzt auch mal eben
mal nach was über verraten deswegen oder
oder hast du gesagt ja wir sind in den
trends direkt hinter ortszeit
ja genau was schon darüber geredet wie
whatsapp und facebook nein habe ich noch
nicht ich hab ich hab ich ja ich finde
es einfach nur ein grundstück auf die
aktive folie kennt ich denke das ganze
ist auf verschiedenen ebenen gut für
facebook einerseits kommerziell dann
bezüglich der inhalte die man da jetzt
neue war es also nsa mäßig datenschutz
packe ich weiß 98 du meinst dass die
unsere daten rippen werke hate you ich
weiß gab kann ich das hütchen hat mir
nicht wehgetan aber dass diese teile
dazu gegangen sind als ich drin stand
die schließen sich die verändert sich
halt und ich stehe da drin und da ist
dann gleich ein loch also kein loch mehr
kanzler gleich mal angucken sonst genau
jetzt ist da weil ich da drin gestand
mir welche zum blog deswegen aber auch
einfach um die konkurrenz aus zu löschen
es sind dann ganz viele verschiedene
gründe und an sich ist es eigentlich ich
finde es eigentlich ich weiß nicht ob
ich es gut finden soll oder ob ich
schlecht finden soll also an alle die
die jetzt nichts mitkriegen jener welt
und einfach nur täglich nur kiffen ist
das kann beispielsweise whatsapp angebot
gemacht über 19 milliarden dollar das
sind umgerechnet 13 millionen 13
milliarden euro
auch wenn es 13 millionen euro werden
aber der kurs aber richtig scheiße
das hier ist gleich vorbei an high speed
12 machen das jetzt vorbei alter dieses
level
das hat ein ende egal jedenfalls ich
weiß nicht ob ich gut oder schlecht sein
soll weiß natürlich geil weil ich denke
dass es auf jeden fall in den nächsten
wochen so sein wird dass endlich das
kommt was ich mir schon so lange wünsche
dass man nur auf dem pc nutzen kann dass
man mit dem pc weil ich bin so oft am pc
und muss dann eben bei mit leuten da mit
dem mit manchen kommuniziert über skype
mit anderen über facebook mit anderen
whatsapp unter sind eigentlich einfach
so gern wenn ich das ganze besser machen
könnten einfach über den pc das ist halt
richtig geil
es gibt zurzeit noch die heißt telegramm
dies auch ganz klar die so wie whatsapp
nur besser also die kann auch auf dem pc
genutzt werden dies ganz cool könnte er
vielleicht mal googeln nur kilogramm
wird natürlich nie so etablieren wie
whatsapp telegramm
weil das schafft einfach keiner hat
mittlerweile 450 millionen nutzern ist
wenn täglich eine million mehr
ich glaube nicht mehr dass so viele
menschen geboren werden wir täglich oder
wartet dann schon mal wieder gezeigt
wie viele neue menschen nicht wie starke
bevölkerungswachstum sterben und werden
täglich geboren
aber ich glaube deutlich mehr zuwachs
der weltbevölkerung pro tag 250.000 aber
zu sein bedeutet nach der zuwachs
beträgt 250.000 und es werden wir
sterben wahrscheinlich denke ich locker
150000 also ist es auf jeden fall so
dass mehr menschen immer geboren werden
weil medizin verbessert sich natürlich
alles mögliche was eigentlich los card
mit ihr hier
viel war das 7 glaube ich mich gerieben
er sich ich weiß nicht aber es ist
natürlich jetzt nicht so geil dass die
ganzen daten nichts von einem wechsel
aber das ist das regt mich eigentlich eh
nicht auf weil man weiß alles über mich
dadurch dass ich ja diese youtube videos
machen und im öffentlichen interesse
stehe
und ich meine ob es jetzt wissen dass
ich meinen kollegen bild von einem
waschbecken geschickt oder nicht als ich
mir jetzt auch egal also von deinem
kollegen sogar einen runter aber noch
meinen penis das ist mir scheißegal also
nicht egal vergessen aber ich finde weiß
nicht es hat auch teilweise werden alle
hassen hier
es hat vielleicht auch was gut ist dass
die daten von uns haben weil dadurch
wird die personalisierte werbung
geschaltet et cetera emmental findet man
dadurch seine neuen fußballschuhe
was hältst du davon also für
personalisierte werbung whatsapp jetzt
von whatsapp personalisierte wirklich
auch nicht nur schlecht also müssen wir
uns als vision von whatsapp facebook ich
finds relativ kraft dass facebook
eigentlich so ziemlich alles übernimmt
snap chat wollten sie auch übernehmen
dies übernommen nicht instagram ihr
instagram übernommen snapshot wollten
sie übernehmen snapshot abgelehnt glaube
ich ja weiß nicht wer da noch viel mehr
wert das stimmt auf jeden fall weiß net
at work bestimmt auch in kassel zuwachs
an nutzern
na ja auf jeden fall ich finde es auch
kraß auf jeden fall also unter diesem
aspekt den sogenannten dass facebooks
bestimmt auf dem pc nutzbar machen würde
egal ob es noch gar nicht gesehen dass
wir echt cool auf jeden fall also ich
weiß nicht ob es so sein wieder was wird
eigentlich ich glaube es wird zu sein
ja es gibt auf jeden fall schon kleine
tricks mit dem man es auch auf jeden
fall nutzen kann auf dem pc luca du
kannst dir einen android emulator
herunterladen und dann whats app
installieren
das hat apple in indien so gemacht das
ist geil
damit wird das ganze auch mal wird also
da kannste könnt ihr einfach mal googlen
passiert wissen wir wie das geht das ist
eigentlich relativ simpel dauert
vielleicht zehn 15 minuten könnt ihr
wartet auf dem pc benutzen auch wenn ihr
gar kein smartphone ab könnt ihr einmal
vom pc schreiben
naja es ist toll und mir also ich finde
es auf jeden fall ja nicht du hast quasi
jetzt irgendwie so ein trick wie man
trotzdem auf dem pc nutzen kann
ja du hast im spielaufbau respekt du
bist weg sagen wir machen nicht zuletzt
dank an alle themen wie rtl noch viel zu
kalt auf und dann will ich zeigen ihnen
die nähte video wieder typisch